1.
Coca-Cola is the second most universally understood
term in the world, just behind "okay".
94% of the world's population understand coca-cola.
2.
There are only 33 non-alcoholic drinks that
generate over 1 billion dolls in revenue.
Coca Cola own 15 of them.
3.
Coca-Cola spend more money on advertising
than Microsoft and Apple combined.
In 2010 they spent a whopping $2.9 billion.
4.
Coca-Cola manufacture so many different beverages
that if you drank one per day, it would take
you over 9 years to try all of them.
They have a scary, 3,500 beverages under their
name.
5.
Despite what you may have been told coins
or teeth won't dissolve in coke when left
overnight.
This is a common misconception.
6.
At one time every glass of coke contained
about 9 milligrams of cocaine.
However it was removed in 1903.
7.
Years ago Coca-Cola launched an all out war
on water.
The campaign was called "Just say no to H2O".
In an attempt to get people to order coke
in restaurants instead of free tap water.
The campaign was quickly stopped once people
started to spread the news around.
8.
It takes 2 litres of water to make 1 litre
of Coca-Cola and over 290 billion litres of
water are used to manufacture coke every year
around the world.
9.
The inventor of Coca-Cola who invented the
drink in 1886, was heavily addicted to morphine.
He died two years after the brand was launched.